hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast importance of measuring
the inhibition of platelet thromboxane
by aspirin in cardiovascular disease
management and Prevention presented by
Luis Lopez Indy medical director Corps
genex incorporated I am Christina
mahalik of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
Roberts is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
questions in the box that appears on the
screen we will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers containing
the education credits please click on
the button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process for obtaining your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Lopez I will now turn the presentation
over to him dr. Lopez
Thank You Kristina for your kind
presentation this morning we are going
to be talking about new developments
that support the use of measuring played
returned obtained and the in addition by
aspirin and how we use this information
in order to manage and prevent you know
cardiovascular disease we are going to
start our discussions by being efficient
in some information some basic
statistics related to cardiovascular
disease we are exposed by the news media
about the impact of cardiovascular
disease not only in healthcare but also
in terms of the economic and cost you
know an impact population this graph
represents you know the prevalence of
cardiovascular disease as you can see
the incidence of this you know diseases
are related to age most of the
individuals are over 40 years old
both women and men and as we can see
that the population you know continues
to live numbered you know we would
expect that kinda vascular disease will
continue to be a a problem in public
health so translating this into members
we see that only in the US for example
there are about 100 million people with
cardiovascular disease and the estimated
cost is in the range of about 300
billion dollars if we you know look at
the number which we know for the rest of
the world and you can see that the
number of you know patients will
increase and that will also increase the
economic cost
over the years you know we have seen
that the rate of mortality of
individuals dying from cardiovascular
disease had been increasing this graph
shows the relative rate going up since
the early nineteen hundred's in which in
employment you know when the you know
1960 that's when you know this was the
study was conducted in Flanagan and
identify some of the most common
cardiovascular risk factors programs in
order to control those of these factors
were implemented at that time however
you know he looked at him up to a in
dividing years the impact of these
burners had been you know not very
effective so today you know most of the
cardiologists and you know in doctors in
public health they considered that the
implementation of this burden had
provided only modest results
well why this you know modest results
and in you know we can probably discuss
that there are causes that we contribute
you know to to these results however we
this discussion you know I can identify
that there are two main problems that
you know should be pointed out one is
and he can be shown in the graph in the
left that the prevalence of obesity in
the adult population 20 to 75 years of
age both men and women showed an apple
you know trend so that is going to
translate obesity include diabetes and
again you know you can see are the
statistics and the projections
you know for the incidence of diabetes
in the world in the next you know 20
years is going to be you know 65% so
these two factors will contribute to you
know the the increase in the incidence
of cardiovascular disease or preventing
you know more effective a you know and
better results in in programs that have
been implemented so in the last decade
you know many groups cardiologists in
and researchers interested in address
ferocious have been leading you know to
review the impact of this classic you
know risk factors you know meaning you
know the classic lipid profile and the
question that they have been asking is
you know have this risk profiles and
risk my mother's had been affected I
show here in this slide a you know the
the one of the early meetings that
concluded that we definitely you know
have not seen in a very good impact by
implementing the biomarkers in you know
we attend you know any of the Atlas
courses for cardiovascular and even in a
population meetings you know very often
we see you know in the primary lectures
maybe most important lecture food for
those are conferences that cardiologist
a leaves the topic of you know
cardiovascular disease in presentations
you know quite often we see you know
titles like widely missed the mark in
preventing cardiovascular disease what I
presented you know here is one of those
lectures that was presented at is pH in
2015 how many Toronto after going to all
the economic impact of cardiovascular
disease you know
economic impact in the population the
conclusion is yeah we are definitely not
preventing cardiovascular disease and
one of the reasons is because we are
failing to develop and use new effective
early risk biomarkers so the answer in
very simple terms this guess we didn't
need new and better and diverse manner
with biomarkers the other concept that I
like to mention in this presentation is
you know be very simple view of what is
a cardiovascular disease and more
specifically the adverse periodic
cardiovascular disease this you know now
we've known that is a chronic and
progressive disease it can be and
usually it's very it is asymptomatic and
even it's the early life the problem is
that adverse Pyaasa staff in utica
factors but to simplify this comes at
you know and what I would like to do is
divide this into two components one is
you know the blue box and you can see
which is systemic so it's a component
that is personally blood and that
component will a result included
activation and platelet aggregation and
when we talk about platelet activation
and aggregation we talk about true
disease those are the molecules that
will activate platelets so you know the
beta initially result in increased
arterial thrombosis at the same time you
know patients without the spherical
reversibility series will have a second
component that is localized in the
tissue and that is really to information
and we can see that with information
that is the you know associated with
abnormalities in lipids activation of
macrophages
the development of the classic you know
dream cells and even a an immunological
response but results below these were so
in the formation of the classic black
in their tail war so these two
components they seem to be separate and
they seem to be you know unrelated
however you know now we are discovering
you know more mechanisms that will
connect in the consensus is that there
is a very active cross communication
crosstalk between the systemic and
difficult issue but today we are going
to be talking mostly about the Thursday
systemic component which is related to
click in activation and how ask me you
need this the ASAC that you see there
you know it's the represents you know
the aspirin use and how has been effects
this first component and in any case how
that effect is going to affect the
crosstrack communication with the other
volunteer component then right there in
the middle of this communication and
going to introduce who in turn that is
called oxidative stress oxidation and
inflammation
so it's an inflammatory response that is
triggered by different oxidation
mechanisms that is called the new
general terms of co2 stress so now this
is becoming you know more and more
important as a factor study
cardiovascular disease and we're going
to refer to this term in Excel
occasionally this presentation the other
component that we need to discuss is the
million or molarity platelets platelets
are you know the main source of these
traditions the platelets you know in
very small cells in the blood but they
have a very active you know a system of
enzymes and metabolic pathways that are
connected to receptors in surface are
represented you know in this diagram
there are very many you know they're
different and many receptors that you
know have different functions today we
are going to focus our discussion
one you know with this a receptor and
metabolic pathway and that is the
pathway that starts with the electronic
acid right in the circle and that you
know I appeal only classes but in
science and going into the control box
in a tree children saying a - is the
main Authority active trouble chain they
will have you know actively plate this
by binding to the receptor which are
losing reception on platelets so this a
pathway is inhibited my asthma so
aspirin you know will decrease the
production term person in a - and the
gives be known between aggregation that
is going to be basically today's
discussion so as I mention trembles in a
tree is the physiologically bioactive
molecule the problem is that this
molecule is very difficult in nation
because the shelf life is very very
short it existing in circulation very
short period time but in that circular
time terms and then to can't promote the
real activation navigation regarding
even you know has already in
hypertension so so what we do is we try
to measure it directly the action
atronics community and for that we go to
a metabolite of Thompson deeply and it's
called eleven decide which removes in b2
in the data is going to be the molecule
that we are going to discuss today you
know and this is production v2 is a
stable metabolite that will reflect the
production Achon using nature so the
question here is can we really use this
in every Hydra trembles and b2
metabolites
that's a biomarker for cardiovascular
risk and in all the discussions is going
to be you know try to address
you know this question now because as I
showed you know aspirin inhibits you
know that 2008 - pathway the aspirin has
been used for many years as a way to
prevent cardiovascular you know disease
in the action of aspirin is on an inside
that is called cox-1 cyclooxygenase one
pathway assimilates inhibits you know
that inside so it will activate an
example the lateral platelets and then
we will produce a decrease of imitation
of chronic symmetry and all the other
downstream metabolites of troops and I
treat now aspirin is being very very
effective and says that it actually
drops most of the cups one activity so
because of that a over the years as well
has been a very cost effective
prevention for after thrombotic
cardiovascular events now here is you
know a summary in in the red box a
summary of the publications that have
open here showing that asthma is a very
good you know drug to prevent
cardiovascular disease well all this
sounds good but there don't see that
that you know there are some problems
with the innovation of chunky chain into
they before we go into that I'd like to
summarize what I just mentioned you know
the the you know the the pathway of the
term obtain a to and Thompson V
production a in the center in table in
the middle we have the membrane
phospholipids that will be metabolized
can vary by the reaction of different
forceful night phases into arachidonic
acid I like it only Cassidy it will be
converted into
several prostaglandins and introduction
into by the action of cyclooxygenase
--is secularism of city noises or [ __ ]
enzymes can be one comes one
uncocks two [ __ ] one is only percent
basically platelets so he [ __ ] one is
you know the action of coxswain is
basically related to platelets and the
tox screen is present in some other
cells like inflammatory cells and they
can also you know coxswain citizens one
in the tree with the dealer's turbos and
a tree because turbos and nature would
use by either these two enzymes and I
will be then you double dive into more
stable you know products and that's the
night onyx and b2 and further in deliver
and further metabolized and excreted you
in the yielding as xi d hide will trump
of seen be true the test that we are
going to talk today use the analyzer
tells that measure the urinary levels of
eleven hypodermics the attention to so
level so here in i Tomlinson - we'll
need the reflection of the term of any
tooth produced either by coxswain or
black ops 2 when we could a patient on
aspirin aspirin as I mentioned before we
only inhibit it cuts one and under this
person of platelets so plateless would
not be able to produce the jungles and
h2 and after we saw would have decreased
levels of b2 and so and during our
eternal 72 however you know we have the
cox-2 pathway on the left side of this
diagram and that
cox-2 is not affected by asthma so if
the initial high levels and trouble
sending to most likely those high levels
usually refer as recipient you know
terminally to
are going to come from the Anna cox-2
pathway and it's not affected by asthma
and we are going to use this concept in
order to you know a nature trouble
saying and see you know how induce the
inhibition of of you know trembles in in
cardiovascular this is management as you
know I indicated as well it has been
used for many years and it has been very
effective in general terms however has
been recognized for points in time that
you're all the patients benefit from
asthma you know sometimes there you know
we can see reports that up to even sixty
percent of patients and especially
populations with active diseases
diabetes reversible they fail to respond
to a smile and you know those individual
have been busted lack of response to be
referred to in the past as aspirin
persistence and now we believe that
prone return is not really you know
richer and more appropriate should be
referred to us who in complete customer
response in Europe some you know people
prefer to call this condition and hype
lately reactivity we are taking as well
the importance of determined in this has
been resistance whether unit respond
good organist went back to aspirate and
is because there has been publications
that associated this lack of response of
assistance husband with cardiovascular
risk
this patients can show to have up to
about 14 times increase the risk for
developing cardiovascular complications
compared to those patients that did
respond well not due to asthma so the
charm of asking resistance has been a
long we are going to use in this
presentation because it's quite common
but we understand
30 days you know responsible as per the
reality
osmond system is not a communicable
entity it's not like a disease or you
know has not been really defined
standardized you and unfortunately there
is no treatment for that so however this
is a an observation that we need to you
know a look for in the laboratory in
order to identify those patients that
have to respond to husband and see you
know how we can then multiply that
increase risk for cardiovascular
complications well what are the
mechanisms of Aspen Food response if it
will give the literature over the three
years you know probably number one is
patient compliance patients that say
that they are not and then you know
there have been publications you know
that suggest that in some cases we have
a turbo chain named pre-production by
over at pathways one of those pathways
is the cox-2 that we just reviewed
between experience life
we have also you know seeing patient
with you know problems because of the
type of aspirin the introduction with
some alerts gastrointestinal approaching
and finally because the personal genetic
variations of the toxin one in science
this actually has been studied in
certain details and it has been shown
that there is no not really important
impact of genetic polymorphism
with the guts man however in the last
few years more and more publications and
now the show that considered the stress
and inflammation the term that I
mentioned before it's now becoming an
emerging factor that explains why these
patients don't respond very well among
this point to aspirin in you know so we
can you know identify those individuals
assessment system
and it's important to use this
information as a you know a way to to
you know notify this condition can be
the clinical relevance of identifying
the actually the system will be you know
as a factor that can be modified in
order to decrease cardiovascular risk
and that's you know growing the main
importance from the clinical point of
the wine we need to identify these
patients three words about the Cascade
that you know the years to measure their
see that this you know is the levity
gradual trembling be to test kit it's in
a nicer for the millinery universities
of this metabolite now I just been in
your approved clear by the US FDA then
it's been in markinson's you know 2007
and basically is you know on here's in
order to provide an aid in the
qualitative detection of the Aspinall
effect so we use this destination
trouble changing themselves where the
aspirin is you know working in this
individuals the we use the eleven hydro
molecule okay as the analyte to measure
you know in his company Eliza because
the eleven dehydrate rumbles in between
as I indicated it's a stable metal ruler
with a long civility half-life and ex
vivo is very stable where on his two
weeks you know in temperature didn't
longer for degrees in the definitely
pros
also its he leaves this metal light
because a we measure this a metabolite
as an indicator about the terms of same
a two generation
until Thomason into is the target for an
aspirin therapy you know by using
healing you know in this system as in
matrix for the function we minimize
pre-analytical values like they need
culture that can be occurred in certain
blood base tells try to nation see the
same in on metabolites so when we
obtained ly blood you know for example
during okay the doing is not subject to
X be able activation this is a very
common problem that we can encounter
with platelet aggregation assets so he
used an random view we can you notice
any you know I mean specimen and nature
determination there however we normalize
the results of you know picograms of let
me have the term the CD to with you in
quality so at the end the results are
normalized you know two people terms of
Tronics in between all the milligrams of
creatine in this way we have a
consistent you know mission in the
trauma city that is usually laboratory
to my patients because of patients in
one you know when common is what you we
are using hearing to measure distances
and why not listen to a we had tried to
two measures to explain in concern and
yeah the probably nature in gives
results for you no one explained that if
you want to be consistent not to have
consistency that you know the sauce you
know all the time
he really provides the best matrix
because in term there are so many
proteins that can interfere with the
protein
because turkic saying is a small
molecule you know you can get
inconsistent and interference with
results one hearing device a matrix that
that has no you know accessibility
normal molecules and therefore it
provides you know very very consistent
clinically useful a you know levels over
time
so the resistive Asian basically urinary
by traversing this mission or innocence
the what one of the question bill is
okay if we can measure troublesome
between what what are the levels that he
used in order to determine whether the
patient is good responder to lesbian or
a bad responder to us but what is what
are what what is the level you know to
determine you know aspirin resistance
not this is one of the early studies
that we performed and a population of
healthy individuals now were measured
narcotics in between levels and without
before taking asthma and she can see in
this graph the distribution of values in
the black bars there has some very wide
range that goes from you know Messner
ruining nine kindly by the way over
6,300 so so the distribution that is
very you know why when you put this
patient on aspirin okay
all these diets eternal synonyms are as
you can see here push to the left so the
majority of the patients are going to be
you know in the range of less than fifty
hundred to the left with the birth so we
use this nine fifteen hundred get this
type of response as
the cutoff to cold plate response to
that response to asthma so you can see
in the citations taking aspirin on the
left on the right side of the vertical
nine in a very small you know nine years
so those will be you know considered
individuals that are not responding
world to us so we have tested many
populations in your county as well as
disease populations using this type of
analysis and for example here you can
see in the that patient with diabetes
the number of patients that have good
response to an increase from seven to
nine percent in healthy subjects to
about 14% and patients populations with
Kate coronary syndromes going up to 33
even 50% so this a cut-off was a bit
lean on another tuna tree to give you
money to classified as an assistant
management system now this graph in the
next line in this line shows you know
this type of results they the blue
columns on the left a represents the
control you know in a population with
the mean value of remission
this patient you are not taking aspirin
this is the baseline you can see that
the mean levels about 2500 and the bars
are arranged the range need not going
all the way up to 10,000 he knew block D
not ideal it's next to that next to the
control we see the mean value increases
goes not about 4000 and the range also
you know is expanded to about 20,000 and
when you have the kicker known single
patients that have
you know more active disease well it
must be see as you can see that means
you know you need medicine or 7000 like
the range go even higher to littles you
know or over 9000 you can see that there
is a tremendous overlap you know in
these divers so we analyze these values
now to boxing in every country in
patience not taking us money and we
could not even get those hydrogen's they
could not predict you know outcomes
Graduate vascular adverse outcomes in
this population so this cannot diminish
the evaluate using you know levity
hydrogen dosing intervals in the
clinical setting because you know those
bodies don't have however if we go to
the break you know graph in red column
these are the percentage of patients
that are painted sponges to aspirin so
these patients have already taking
aspirin and and you can see that the
control have you know a 7% of patients
who've miss my husband diabetes double
as we have seen before anyone have to go
30 percent with acute coronary syndrome
patients however you know you heroes
this data these numbers after taking us
from living fragments and taking us in
then the projections the statistical
analysis to predict you know very much
adverse outcomes and we could actually
doctor hit so these values have good
predicted like and so we are you know
now you know saying that this is the
aspirin response on the lack of as many
response after take investment
those divers have clinical utility in
predicting you know outcomes so it
becomes important from the laboratory
you know - you know implement a test kit
to measure to test for hospital
assistance so we are proposing that you
know when the dovetails is the early
test so we test that we measure we
mentioned before and that test will
measure the production of learning and
retrieves in between with this is the
metabolite that reflects you know to us
an entry in a patient that is taking
aspirin okay that 11 the kind of trauma
can be treated and we measure the
details is basically a reflection on
terms of seeing a - okay then that is an
indication of you know a direct effect
of innovation catchment by miasma there
are all the tests that you can use and
it's being called some laboratory tears
that are based on blood so God tells the
National Resistance rely on regular
stimulation and you know the paper
responds to diverse mechanisms here is
that you know we tend to stimulate those
patients using many of those receptors
that I show you know in various lines
you can see that there are different
tests in the market listing here taken
works btg very fine now if both of
stairs
depend on you know extraction of date
that's in stimulation with a veneers and
admission you know that plated
responsive navigation problem is that
these stairs have been shown over the
years that they don't correlate very
well at each other and they donate
correlate very well eternity to
production so probably you know part of
the explanation is that this there's no
denying so many older
you know receptors in pathways the
stimuli the delegation that you know I'm
not excited maybe we refer to know the
correlation studies so we posted that
32% is negative healthy is going to be
you know the most direct in killing way
and you know that's the data that we are
going to be presented a not recently you
know we have run into you know different
results from different groups some
collaborators they tried to to to
address the question what is now the the
clinical utility what is the clinical
correlation on here in area Trump of
saying with cardiovascular risk factors
one recent set of publications that was
presented in the I must highest HD
recently read that nature urinary total
of 73 in population in fact two
identities that were in all patients
taking aspirin and also nature
conservatory markers like CRP hyper
popular abilities you know it the RTD G
and hydrated way activity like platelet
aggregation ventilation acids then you
know these patients were separated by
you know the degree information therapy
in high information and no information
as you can see in less you know graph
okay in the middle graph you're going to
see high hyper for your ability and your
hyper by the nobility and in the graph
right side a pre radiation high platelet
aggregation
raishin so you can see that in every
hydraulics it will correlate with him on
low levels of inflammation and low
levels of trauma same high levels of
inflammation kind levels of truth and
the same beam on street or the TEG
so if this indicates that he follows
little because the levels follow the
universe you know information had the
community and plate aggregation or risk
factor for cardiovascular disease one
other question is how could the two
exchanged between compares with platelet
aggregation as I will say that you only
find more independent paper not
publishing the literature that measure
the urinary terms of 72 side by side in
a patient with stroke this and also you
know measure platelet aggregation might
be very fine now which is you know one
of the litigation essays this
publication was published you know in
Thailand and the reference is dirt road
to reveal if interesting what happened
is that in this publication the trouble
saying detected 40 percent on his stroke
population as fashionable system and you
know a very fine now they take the
quality six percent as a fluid system as
you can see cable the way to the
interpret these results in schools right
forty percent and 6 percent the adverse
outcomes were you know studying in this
population and as you can see the nearly
hydrophobic same correlated 40 percent
correlated with 18 percent of mortality
in you know in this patient population
and the six percent for
only two percent on mortality great
so what interpretation is that very fine
now Neil's about you know 15% to 16% of
immortality rate in his patient
population by not detecting those
patients with aspirin system so he you
know have seen this type of results
morning before concern in many other
publications indicated the quality unite
rhombus MVP has a better correlation
with adverse outcomes and this this
slide represents a summary meta-analysis
published a few years ago you know
several 20 25 different publications
thousands of patients that they would
classify as hospital system and then
correlate that output assistance with
cardiovascular outcomes community works
but you can see is then in the middle
the vertical nine had to the right of
the vertical 9 there means increased
cardiovascular risk to the left most of
these publications said probably one and
now has you know have indicated how
correlated as well system cardiovascular
risk this is along this information that
both you know we mentioned in earnings
and presentation that told us when
response correlates with increased
cardiovascular risk two studies that
were done you know some years ago the
hopes that in 2002 and this man 2000
Iran first studies that show Hydra CC b2
as the marker to you know assess
cardiovascular complications this study
was done in about 500 patients in
cardiovascular disease involve taking
aspirin as you can see in the graph the
higher the level in terms of Cindy
Ranieri tumble sent me to you you know
follows the increased risk for
complications and that also included
death so the question here is what makes
the patients with Hospital Ashbury
response on aspirin assistance different
what makes them you know more prone to
complications in why they have increased
mortality the several years ago with
liberators we study our patients and
that population of patients with
coronary artery bypass they're worth
taking that's when we measure certain
CRP Hispanic population as a marker for
inflammation and you can see those
results on the Left graph and on the
right graph a healing i8i so each year
to our first landing after alpha this
matter
a lady died so pgf plasma is a marker
for in vivo oxidation this in case you
know see at the background you can see
here that certain CRP is higher in
patients that are no responders to us
when compared to patients responsible
and here also for it I saw is the same
distribution higher in vivo oxidation if
patients so it it is you know clear in
his study that there was an oxidative
inflammatory background in those
patients that have pool asthma response
so to test be further described focuses
in collaboration with conferencing in a
bigger University because it must be
called
we study a North patient population that
we're you know diagnosed so having the
gospel it sees my angiography
and you can see the criterion given box
you know both these patients about you
know 449 where patients that we take in
aspirate and have complete information
samples with that to be able to be
included in the study then we measure in
these patients a by Elijah the urinary
levels of 1922 and there was a marker
for Aspinall response at the same time
and same patients we know in the nation
in Italian IEEE 8022 alpha which is a
summation oxidation and we used the
Eli's the the deliberately hiding from
boxing entry and levels to classify the
patients in yogurt our group in the
middle third country and another country
now you can see you know here the
patients in the lower turtle so after
taking us when we have low levels of
trembling so they Pro can be classified
as Venus Ponder's the mortality rate in
this population is only three points
them this is a maternity rate in the
middle third time you can see down at
the bottom but you need one is 18
percent and then in the a potato but you
know in spite of tech industry they have
her in electronics in the ink
alternatively increased to 25 percent so
definitely there was
an association seem to be an association
between you know eleven Heidel you know
levels after taking aspirin and
mortality rates now in this graph he has
the summary of the different clinical
and demographic variables that can be
studied this population this is a VC
graph only to point out at the bottom of
this table in the green table knowing
that in a leadership eg to Elsa was
worth of the very important in
statistical significant in your
association with 1100 choosing between
towns so this suggested that there was
an association between higher levels of
nitronic Cindy - but also high levels of
a Tyson pigeon - lhasa as we have seen
before when we do the statistical
analysis the adjusted and Emma just you
know linear regression I just want to
point out that in the green you know
section of the table you can see that 11
behaviour on boxing you know a nice of
peachy blue alpha continues to be a very
very strong association but independent
in association with the 1127 females
so it clearly showed that these two
values ranging in age I suppose things
were somewhat you know interacting in
person in clinical relevance this slide
shows the visual representations of two
tables that I just mentioned so
basically the
in the left side is the on the
horizontal axis the 2011 behind rule
changes in v2 and in the vertical a
dyson PG to Martha as you can see I
think leasing levels
Otunga same with the turtles also follow
increasing levels
no more symmetry and the correlation a
strong correlation between these two
variables is shown so it me review the
statistical you know interpretation and
analysis after you know all this data
its conclusion is that patients that do
respond to aspirin so in spite of
husband did have increasing levels of
transitioning these patients at the same
time I'm going to have an independent
the increasing in parallel increasing
levels of a nice LPG to lava I'm going
to put them these results in a graphic
representation so I modify the slide
that I presented in early for the you
know the metabolic pathway of production
or pH unboxing so what I did here is I
you know try to separate the platelet
pathway or
Cookson one pathway that you can see in
the right side on this night okay the
platelets will produce arachidonic acid
and it rocks one will be inhibited by
aspirin so there will be no production
actually I'm saying they true so when
you put a patient on asthma in
individuals we say most of them respond
very valuable enhancements and basically
when you do is you eliminate the pathway
from the equation so you can see that so
whatever is left in that individual that
is taking aspirin it's going to come
from the
cemetery pathway in this case
inflammatory that means Minister between
basically basically two cells
macrophages and anything yourselves you
know probably in the fetal cells have
been able to go kill this inflammatory
cells will also produce in a lacunae
classic arachidonic acid can be been
converted in double knives by going to
the left by the inflammatory cockpit
pathway in patron go chain into it oh
that arachidonic acid in the middle is
going to be further you know metabolize
converted by the action of reactive
oxygen species the world's here
represents the axilla t'v you know
attack and this is a non enzymatic
activity perfectly and produce you know
a lesser PG to alpha so patients there
are not many that don't respond whether
your trust me because it had levels of
distribution the dimensions they also
going to have high levels of metal
hydrogen now there are now serving in
vitro publication that have clearly show
that they - a PDF to alpha can stimulate
directly the terms of cell receptor of
platelets so now these patients have
stimulation it leads back to the thermos
in v2 and in a dyson 18 tomorrow how
this
influence mortality you know this study
you know this information has been
recently published a if you look at you
know first the term book same third
tiles its own personnel service that's
at the in Aspen you see in the graph on
the left that you know what turtle had a
very long time to greater the not
mentioned before but when you go to the
middle turtle the new Titan rate
increases significantly and increasing
value when we go to the upper third down
on the right of this you have this read
this Bible little curves which is you
know his reflection maybe time to rate
and you can see how you know they talk
to it decrease okay over time no dear we
do the similar analysis but incorporate
you know the a tie so pgf to alpha you
can see in the lower half of this graph
on the website the first two columns is
the new term boxing between with no they
died so and hi a Tyson the mortality
rate is in a relatively low compared to
the right side of this which represents
high trauma team and you know the a
Dyson and high a nice impeaching to
Martha so the combination of these two
terms in and a national into alpha
building where you know the mortality
rates in this population and if you do
the same analysis for survival estimates
you know all the time you are going to
see that there is definitely no an
interaction between between these two by
you know decreasing is survival rates
you know in this population so
the way the leaders can you know use the
1500 cutoff that we you know the
tournament before in order to call the
patient what has been an assistant to a
speedy response and how you know for the
addiction and utility and can this new
number will be a key value in you to to
to further studies
- you need to minimize in this graph
would be that you know time is basically
an IOC you know analysis you know then
we determine that in this analysis the
optimum flowing in this curve from the
tality rate corresponding to the 1597 so
their corresponding to be 1511 in which
not determine you know before so this
indicates that the 1500 is a head of
pain that we can pinnacle dragging into
assessment activates in in you know and
and guides me before I go to finally
conclude and you know this presentation
it's just what I mentioned briefly that
in the most recent recommendations for
assessing and it has been a risk a the
one of the focal points that that the
recommendations have published is that
we we have to target cardiovascular risk
not just cholesterol and
you know to modify the cardiovascular
risk statins are probably right now any
medications that seem to be doing you
know they may be job then we better kind
of focus on the bad cholesterol in there
are more importantly especially for this
discussion is the new recommendations
now are included a you know all the
factors and one of the factors that they
the different innovation occurred in
information therapy and simply as an
indicator for information so information
is becoming an important factor in
cardiovascular see in most recently you
know this is body miss procedures not
two or three months ago in the
cardiovascular meeting in Europe that
that for the first time you know there
is a drug that has been used in order to
to attack the inflammation in
cardiovascular disease to prevent you
know the heart attacks okay and this is
a new a very different approach than
just building cholesterol so this is you
know indicating that that there are
single factor that had to deal with
inflammation in you know in the vascular
disease and that the factor is not
interleukin-1 beta and that has been you
know in
indicated that the informations and all
those factors besides you need just to
cholesterol Dayton in vascular
management and hopefully new in
improving the candlestick you know
utility for early prevention of
cardiovascular disease so unleashing
this because this information is tied to
we just mentioned that there is
oxidation this information there are all
factors that
and development and vascular disease and
they also pretended to nobility and
mortality and we need to pay attention
to the inspectors so the clinical
interpretation for Olympic hydro turbine
into can be you know summarizing this in
this way you know only valuable for
patients taking aspirin I think that's
the best utility of this information
only taking aspirin if you are to take
announcement you'll have levels that are
troublesome be too and that below 1500
okay then you have an okay
you know minimum risk there's no further
action it's poorly necessary and the
reason for that is because you don't
wanna keep pushing aspirin in these
individuals and increase the risk for
not bleeding and some other
complications but if you are responding
to the aspirin so you will have levels
over 15 and then you are going to have
an increase from cardiovascular risk you
better check you know for some other
reasons that that you know terms and
levels are not very long that compliance
notional aspirin drug interference that
but if you rule out these causes then we
need to then have to notify you know the
patient management by modifying those
who trust me or Adam you know additional
medications and growing some other cox-2
inhibitors or anti altered platelets or
other anti-inflammatory medication to
you know you know minimize the levels of
chronic same as the so in summary we put
all the information together we can
say the following the a11 had returned
axilla measurements after you take
aspirin are important for the following
reasons one that you can identify those
paces will pull responsible asthma you
know you can identify the patient
investment system by identifying those
patients that are responders to lastly
you know because you need to pay
attention to the increase cardiovascular
risk and that you know reflects also a
natality indication time to rate and
decrease your vitals in five years and
finally those responders will require
additional and Eternity antiplatelet or
an eternity or anti antioxidant relation
intervention and this is basically the
final message and I want to thank you
for your attention and have now you know
the main to answer any questions or
comments that you might have
thank you very much presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window and type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for so without further ado let's
get started with our first question of
the day and that and that question asks
can you test for urinary xi dehydrated
for boxing be two levels and patients
not taking aspirin I I haven't heard any
questions
okay there is one question here that I
just received can you test the new 911
dragon turbo send it to you levels
annotations not taking us we're like yes
the answer is that the way you can
measure those levels however the
clinical utility the clinical value
those levels are limited and you know
the obsession there is a wide range of
millinery you know chunk of 72 levels in
normal population in diabetes and
cardiovascular disease patients with a
significant overlap so the you know the
clinical value that information is that
you know the that they should be to have
you know and background we exceeded the
stress in the cognate increased
cardiovascular risk however you know in
order to be absolutely sure and increase
the obviously the information it's
better to put those patients on aspirin
and then measure the amino terminus
announced after the investment because
those trend excellent levels have
clinical value in increased correlation
with complications increase mortality
you need so that's why you can measure
you know levels of millenarianism
between phases not taken husband but the
clinical value the clinical utility will
be limited it may have to be interpreted
with caution best managers
but thank you for that answer the next
question of the day asks why is urine
used as sample matrix instead of serum
or plaza for measuring 11 d hydrothermal
seen B - yes the simple answer is that
you know chunk of 72 is a very small
molecule and it's subject to
interference but you know many other
substances that can be present in matrix
so we do have certain you can probably
initial now the small molecule
determinant B - Knology but the presence
of all the larger in high concentration
proteins they interfere you know with
the with the test so so he tried that if
you don't you know he surveys test but
we could not get the pass eight were in
a consistent way for clinical use in the
laboratory you know that you have to
have you know consistency not to not
have all the time you know and so on and
the best results that we will not
entertain and with all the clinical
correlation if with the million matrix
because the kidney naturally removes you
know all these excess proteins then
cleans in all the matrix so then we
measure you know this small molecule you
know it will have a lot less
interference and therefore more
consistent results increase the clinic
at 19
thank you well once again thank you for
your answer we appreciate it
dude it looks like we're running out of
time today so the last question of the
day will we'll ask is 24-hour urine
collection more accurate than random
urine sample to measure 1111 dehydrated
they're boxing B - yes
you know you can use 24-hour urine and
you know to to measure you know
Thomasson into levels he however we can
overcome that issue in not producing
creatinine urinary threatening levels
and the racial troublesome be two levels
over creatinine in any spot village or
any random you know rendering obtain
human so that we don't have to like
listen you threaten we don't have to
connect 24-hour you know you know in the
results are very consistent in yeah
I would like to once again thank dr.
Lopez for his presentation today I would
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through February
2018 you will receive an email from lab
roots
letting you know that the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live events
for now this is Christina with lab
routes thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you here again soon
goodbye